un café de la plage redéfinit est
consacrée aux groupes locaux
pour cette saison la ville de mort pas à
changer sa politique culturelle
une des raisons un manque d'attrait du
public probablement une saison pas très
attirante peu de place au café de la
plage donc beaucoup de groupes ne sont
pas intéressés par ces petites ces
petites zones et puis nous ça nous coûte
très très cher
les coûts sont très importants les
entrées ont beaucoup diminué
finalement assez peu de maurepas siens
au café de la plage donc il fallait qu
on réoriente notre politique ce qui
était compliqué si vous voulez c'est
qu'on avait un budget programmation
environ 20000 euros en 2016
35000 euros en
2010 est donc une augmentation de 15
mille euros pour le café de la plage
grâce au fonds de concours de saint
quentin en yvelines
malgré sept
cette augmentation de
de dotations sur la programmation on n'a
pas vu des faits se faire sentir sur le
public
le café accueillera aussi des
expositions les têtes d'affiché elles
seront reçues à l'espace albert camus
d'une plus grande capacité d'accueil une
décision découverte pendant l'été par
l'opposition certains élus y voit une
structure vidé de sa substance
d'autres comme michel chat pas un
désintérêt pour la jeunesse je n'ai pas
connaissance qui ait eu un travail de
commission pour réfléchir à ces
questions comme d'habitude sous couvert
de mutualisation sous couvert dans
réorientation de fait l'activité du café
de la plage est terminée une fermeture
démentie par la majorité municipale la
saison culturelle de mort par reprend le
23 septembre